hey guys it's max angelica and vadim and
today we will see if samsung's brand new
s22 ultra's camera system is really that
much better than the s21 ultra and the
note 20 ultra let me remind you guys
that max went out and took 30 photos
with all three of these cameras three
generations and he set them all up and
we have not seen any of them and we're
gonna be voting on which one is the best
so go ahead and get a piece of paper and
a pen play along with us write down your
scores and let us know in the comments
and we will see if newer is actually
better so here is our first image this
is a portrait shot with telephoto all
right right off the bat this is very
hard now that there's three of them
compared to the last one we did with the
iphone 13 pro max by the way be sure to
watch that but i think i like the one on
the left
because of the kind of highlight roll
off and contrast on her face and the
detail i absolutely agree the one on the
right seems like it's losing a lot of
detail some parts are too blown out some
parts aren't i didn't see that on the
rack right
and the left one there's way more detail
in their face like you said highlight
roll off while the middle one looks flat
let's hope that's the brand new s22 see
and it is
there you go first point yeah the note
actually has to digitally crop in it
doesn't have that 3x lens here we have
an ultra wide beautiful sunset which
photo is best okay the left one is cut
out because of that massive flaring yeah
and then man it's a difficult one but i
think i'm gonna go with the middle
i agree yes
s21 ultra yeah look the dynamic range
looks better around look here and then
yeah the note 20 had that flaring and i
did clean the lenses all the time
here we have another ultra wide back lit
with no up there on that rock left
yep i like the left you could see his
face the more most uh clearly i guess i
agree right yeah this one looks like the
iphone photo much darker silhouette yeah
s22 as well so the dynamic range like
the sunset you're right the colors
all right so maybe uh samsung does have
something going with this new phone
and we have our first selfie i kept it
limited
wow
interesting yeah the left uh
it's flat it's automatically out and i
really like the center because it's just
brought up and it looks like
by far the most detailed
yeah the one on the right seems like
it's
pushing it with the dark side crush look
at the beard it's like black what if i
like my beard black
yeah center for me i agree okay
have we ever had just like
this happened good improvement
all right and this is a video so this is
8k all three of these cameras can shoot
ak so let's take a look
okay right off the bat the left one has
a bunch of shake it seems like
so i'm not liking that
the two on the right are pretty similar
so far
the one in the center seems to be a
little brighter
whoa these are just like focus hunting
like crazy the right one i think didn't
have any focus hunting at all
it's tough i'm going with the right to
me
personally i saw more detail with the
left one the whole time i thought it was
more detailed than the others
but then the focus
do you guys remember when the s20 came
out and had a bunch of focusing issues
that was terrible obviously it's not
here
all right so which one are you guys
going for but he did right
right because it didn't focus i would
have gone with the left until that point
focus hunting you don't want that in
your video i don't want my videos to be
ruined
s22 ultra that's what i got one
interesting thing is that when i was
recording these the note 20 didn't
stabilize at all when i was recording
and it was like slightly wider maybe
that's why it looks sharper at times and
then it only does stabilization later in
the background which these two look nice
and smooth but yeah the s22 ultra looks
like they fixed the focus issue it's
good
and here we have another shot
what do you guys think wow wow
yeah there's no noise first of all the
left one has a ton of noise this one's
very soft right one's incredibly good
yeah right one
s22 ultra again it's proving itself it
is and all of these have 108 megapixels
sensors and this shot was using that 100
megapixel mode but what you guys just
saw is just the difference in processing
maybe the new um s what do they call it
s8 gen1 i keep forgetting
same sensors are very similar but looks
a lot better we got a portrait here with
noah this one is quite difficult because
they are so similar but if you take a
really close look i think the one in the
center
has the most amount of detail even
though it messed up a little bit on the
cutouts i think it was a difficult
situation i'm going with the center
still
i'm going with the right i like that one
the most the cutout really bothers me it
looks like little like feather
parrot hair going on s22 ultra thank god
for angelica looks the sharpest for some
reason
yeah i wonder why yeah but that cutout
does bug me
and we got this bad boy
wow
wow the one on the right
yeah i mean it's got to be the
right right one right the right one it's
gotta be the
honestly i'm gonna go with the left i'm
going to the left because the one in the
center has like massive over sharpening
and look there's no color here yeah look
at the color captured and look at this
potato camp
[Laughter]
s22 ultra so that's killing it when
you're zooming in
and this is actually like a 30 times
zoom in is it yeah it the image looks
something you'd want to keep yeah here
you know that one wasn't actually as
zoomed in for the telephoto
and we got this bad boy here wow
all these look like dslr shots they all
look good they're not bad at all okay
this one's pretty difficult i know the
one in the center is not good
and between the left and the right i
think i see a little bit more detail on
the left i'm debating between the left
and the right if you look at the left
one like the shingles on the roof you
can actually see the lines here where
you can't on the right however
all of the darks are just
too dark on these and they're kind of
brought up on the right one and i think
i like that more so i'm going to the
right okay
all right
you guys spotted the note i was just
shocked that the last photo we did looks
so terrible at the note this is 10x on
all these in good lighting they're all
good i thought they're pretty dang close
and we got an ultra right here in a
really tough backlit situation let's
know i like the left yeah the one on the
right is insanely blue in terms of the
snow and i think i see the most detail
on the left i'm going with that one i'm
going with the left as well if you look
at the darks they're pretty crushed here
but you can see it pretty darn well over
here yeah
this is good this is noticeable it's
interesting that they the white balance
is just excellent on these
and we got this shot right here
yep
left again left
s22
all the zoom shots this is crazy and
this is actually not using the telephoto
lens
this is not using that telephoto i don't
have too many telephoto shots uh this is
3x so both of these have 3x lenses
this actually has to do a crop and you
use that 3x for portraits and all sorts
of stuff
got another selfie this is an extreme
tough situation i'm actually standing
underneath somewhere where it's dark wow
i like the one on the right
a lot
i like how it's kind of blurry in the
background and you kind of stand out or
with these the background is like so
sharp yeah it kind of gets in the way
yeah i think i'd have to agree because
if you look here there's a lot of noise
in your jacket and it's also a little
bit soft
the one on the right is like on point
the highlight roll-off is really good on
his face look at my beard look how
detailed it is i'm just going to jump in
here
s22
like we showed off with the iphone
the selfie camera on the s22 ultra is
phenomenal really good
and we got this shot here
super tough shot this is a portrait shot
ah man
for me it's got to be
the center the one on the left is just
way too flat the one on the right is
just too crushed
good middle ground in the center
and always kind of messed up
some of this here that was just way too
hard i guess interesting
and then we got one inside this is very
low lights and conditions so for me the
one in the center looks
the worst so between the left and the
right i'm gonna go with the right it's
definitely the sharpest in terms of
seeing the text
and i also like the the white balance i
guess
yeah i would have changed it a little
bit i agree and i also noticed a lot
more detail in the sweater it's true
no
what
the no wow
hey that was unanimous what
not that good interesting maybe it's the
same algorithm i don't know
all right this is insanity here this is
a portrait then portrait
low light
highlights
stuff everywhere i honestly thought
these images are gonna have to be thrown
away because of how insanely hard this
was this is very tough um even though
the dynamic range on the right
is the best i'm going to choose the
center because it didn't totally mess up
this candle
this one is completely screwed up it's
like half blurred
i'm going with the center i may have the
wrong opinion here but when you look at
like
the background and everything here looks
like there's some like weird reflections
the candle looks a little messed up here
everything around it is perfect but the
subject
subject itself really pops on the right
one
i'm i'm gonna go with it okay and that's
the garbage one right yeah
i got this s21 is the garbage one the
each
it's crazy how close these are very
close
and we got this fishy fishy
instantly the right in an aquarium the
right is by far like instantly
noticeable
s22
i actually took a few different ones uh
because it was tough to do this and
every photo i took
the s22 looked sharp
contrasty and these just looked low
contrast so i don't know what they did
but through window and aquarium shots
much better now
this is
very low light
very low light definitely the right
zoomed in instantly the right for me yep
you could actually see all the creases
and the leaves
no notes
wow these two look so weird how's the no
a few shots back um you guys saw that
the three times
lost on the note by a lot because it
doesn't have that three times lens but
here not having that three times lens
meant it used the larger sensor
and digitally cropped and it looks much
better which is crazy and we got a shot
of noah here nice
center easy one for the center for me
yeah this one looks so distorted i i
can't it's so distracting
know it again awesome
right now towards the end let's see what
keeps happening oh okay
huh i'll just say the iphone would suck
at this photo probably i don't see the
left i'm going with the right
all right
yeah s21 and s22 see this one's like
really blown out and just over
contrasted like over sharpening see this
looks not contrasty enough it looks
i'll go for the note
all right we have this beautiful
nighttime shot in
pitch darkness alright so there's a
bunch of botchiness here yeah i don't
like it it's smeared tons of weird noise
artifacts they're right it's very clean
i like how the sky is black and
everything's just sharp so right yep by
far s22 nice hey good job samson
and we got this portrait telephoto shot
it's the center for me just looking at
the detail everywhere their hats and all
the fur all the little hair details
i like it better i agree no
what
you know what i just realized it now
once again the note doesn't have like
when you go into portrait it goes into
the 3 3 3x portrait mode
and the note uses the main sensor
because it doesn't have that lens and it
looks better that's crazy wow
and we got this shot right here i like
the one on the right it looks like to be
uh
the most detailed tons of noise on the
left don't like it so one of the right
for sure yeah no do it again wait why is
this the worst s22 is the worst here
i think processing wow i think
processing let's keep moving
we got this portrait shot
wide angle this time i'm choosing the
one on the right it looks the most clean
um it has all the contrast and detail
and these two are kind of flat
they're so flat this is all blue
overcast everywhere this is so great
okay the right is the s22
remember when we saw the flaring shots
earlier
look how well controlled the flaring
from this looks amazing it might be the
glass probably they have yeah wow well
well i mean it's yeah yeah i mean
center for sure
s22 what was this i thought i wasn't
going to use this
but i took multiple shots with all of
them
s22 kept nailing it these two would not
do it okay so
very good i'm cutting everything out i
mean except for that little piece but
yeah but it looks like you'd want to
keep it yeah
and we got this nighttime shot
wow
i'm going for the right wow like samsung
is doing a good job with the night mode
because this has messed up the sky
artifacts this is messed up the one on
the right insanely clean
s22 good so good
and we got this bad boy right here right
instantly instantly yep
yep the one on the right very clean
sharp details everywhere even way back
here it looks so much better
so much
s22
and we got a video right now okay
this is 4k video they advertise their
nightography right or video whatever
they call it something
i mean right away the center is horrible
the left noise all over the place the
right is by far the most clean i'm
seeing a lot of noise on the right are
you do you want to look head-on i don't
know looks better than the left honestly
center's the worst for sure
yeah oh look how soft yeah the right
look at all the detail
the right for sure
s22
and we got this shot
okay this was
how are you supposed to choose
i don't know this is out of focus it's
back focused
and it didn't do portrait
i mean it has to be the right the right
is the only one that's focused
and portraits on so i will say this was
like the torture test this was
pitch black
yeah super dark back lit
and the note 20 did better probably
because the main lesson is way back
focused yes can't use that
we saw a couple issues with it earlier
right the three times lens earlier oh
yeah
okay this is the astrophotography shot
on a tripod 30 second exposure wow the
one on the right yeah
the one the right kills it the one on
the left is completely flat it's all
like gray here you're getting all these
uh compression lines right
yeah whatever the ending banding yep the
one on the right super clean yeah that's
20 s22
this one whoa this is an ultra wide shot
here same thing the one on the right the
one on the right yeah so all these are
30 second exposures here what's
happening
did you miss labeling nope i did it i
triple checked what
um
it just seems like samsung really
focused on the main lens this time the
the selfie and the main which is what
most people use the ultra ride didn't
change that much three axes so so but
the main and the selfie is excellent and
that is it that's the last one that is
it interesting wow so you guys out there
make sure you tally up what you guys got
comment down below what your score was
and if you didn't at least comment what
blew your mind from this comparison
and let's see what we got so vadim
actually let's have angelica go first
angelica i got 19 for the s22
eight
for the note and three for the s21 so
the s21 got the worst terrible yeah the
note got that's crazy second place by a
lot wow okay i mean we told you guys
last year that the s21 was not good it
was not good i got the same score three
for the s21
got eight for the note and 19 for the
s22 so the s22 killed it by [ __ ] yeah
this might have been the biggest
difference we have ever seen in a triple
comparison
that is incredible so that just shows
noticeable if you have an s21 you think
about upgrading and you can't run
cameras
make the upgrade and even though you
guys chose differently on some the
results ended up being the same so
overall i am blown away yeah
they've made huge improvements with this
new one
and the design looks good the design
looks good this design looks horrible
i'm going to tell you guys
it's ugly and we got the s pen built in
here if you care about that so guys if
you have not yet seen our triple
comparison with all of these phones
going over the speakers the displays the
performance and a lot more click right
over there so you guys can check it out
click above to subscribe to help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
and we will see you in the next video
[Music]